food and wine lovers raise your hand
s flipping can in Las Vegas is bringing
springix are on set
on Saturday here to tell us more is
Richard swoboda welcome to Las Vegas now
thank you thank you thank you for
bringing the drink to celebrate Friday
absolutely yes so we've got our second
annual Tropicana wine mixer of repeating
the event from last year a little bit
different formats oh okay so how was
last year in comparison so last year was
kind of a walk around event an education
piece this will be more of a tasting
event held in our Cabana room okay so we
have a great uh a variety of wines here
for tasting and our VIP event I love
before we get it to the VIP part sure
for anyone with any kind of ticket you
get one of these booklets right
absolutely it's just so cool so when I
walk so when I open it there's notes
here there's a list of all the wines why
is this going to help you throughout the
evening so that'll help you know what
wines you're going to be tasting and
what to look for and it also provides a
space where you can write some notes
down as well some tasting notes as you
go through the event I love that and
it's a great time it's a great way to
hang out with your friends but also
Network a little bit to get to know new
people too so all of this comes with
what's the process like when you get
there you get your booklet and you just
go around and taste so you'll get your
booklet you'll walk around the venue
there and you can start anywhere you
like and you can taste whatever wines
you want to start and finish we also
have some food from our restaurants that
we're offering as well some small bites
from Oakville Steakhouse and also from
Robert Irvine's Public House and Red
Lotus oh that's perfect so the breakdown
you know you are food and beverage
master so break down what kind of wines
we're drinking and why they're so
special absolutely so starting with the
VIP event which is just uh for VIP
guests that buy that ticket six o'clock
we're tasting uh Opus 2016. and we're
also tasting uh Moe and Shandon Rose
and then these are just a few of the
wines that we're going to be uh
showcasing there for tasting as well and
this is for everyone okay okay so we
have the Stags leave Artemis a fantastic
Cabernet
we have Robert Mondavi Chardonnay a
classic Napa Valley chardonnay
and we also have patson Hall which is a
Sonoma Chardonnay a little bit different
and then of course we have some
fantastic French champagne as well I
love it my mom I know she's watching
she's like mouth-watering right now she
loves her cat um now I know you have a
glass port for me yes I do so when I
taste it let's get let's go through the
little tasting portion here what do you
want to just do a little do a little
swirl to kind of activate the uh the
scent in the wine and then you just uh
yep give it a taste kind of let it flow
through your mouth a little bit kind of
get all the flavors wow okay what am I
drinking uh you're drinking Robert
Mondavi Cabernet
es
now there's also live entertainment
there's Raffles so how can people get
tickets to this oh you can get tickets
at Ticketmaster or you can pick them up
at the Tropicana box office
cheers thank you cheers thank you
Richard all right the second annual
Tropicana wine mixer is happening
tomorrow night at The Havana room it's
all going to be all kind of Vibes no sin
city Chronicles probably know something
about the Tropicana Havana absolutely